[Music]
i'm moving the asset
we go now
[Music]
we lost the osprey extraction
we have the governor's daughter i
promised i would keep her safe
with militia group in close proximity
they will come for us i wonder what this
place is
no one here okay but where did they go
looks like the driver was cut up and
dragged out about what
he's torn to pieces of lion gutter some
lions go
how do you know it's a she females are
the true killers
do you want to take a stand here
this is
light them up
[Music]
me
there's an old native american proverb
that says
inside every person there are two bears
forever locked in combat for your soul
one bear
is all things good compassion love
trust the other is all things
evil fear shame
and self-destruction
what's happening
don't let go of my head
what's happening here
hide here i have to go help them no
no dad please please don't leave me
alone danny
i have to go back stay here
my god
wow
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all of you have killed someone
if you weren't here you've been present
or worse and your mutants
are dangerous
we know
[Music]
this place takes your greatest fears
[Music]
what are you doing gotta get better
someday
stephen bear let's play a game
i've been thinking to make with my hands
by myself
a wooden puppet
[Music]
pinocchio try say something
my son is born from one day to the next
what do you mean for one day for one
minute
to the next watch me and one
and two if you do like me in two or
three days you'll be walking by your
i know a certain place called the field
of miracles
[Music]
put him in pleasure how come he prison
[Music]
what's going on with
and now ladies and gentlemen the donkey
knocks you
[Music]
how did you grow up it's a secret you
know i don't want to be
a puppet i want to become a boy like all
the others
[Music]
i've robbed 12 banks in seven states
i have a little over nine million
dollars in cash
and no one knows who i am
bureau of investigation i want to turn
myself in i want to make a deal
what kind of deal i hand over all the
money i stole in exchange for a reduced
sentence
it's important and what's so important
about it i met a woman
i want to be with her for the rest of my
life without lying about my past
[Music]
special agent hall this is special agent
evans where's the money
the man just telling the truth we can
take this money for ourselves
let's do it
whoa whoa i'm turning myself in fbi open
up
what exactly
his real name is thomas dolan former
marine demolitions expert
we needed to come clean i'm not a bank
robber anymore but the murder one charge
for killing one of their own
the feds will come after me and keep
coming those two crooked cops are
willing to kill another agent
what are they capable of doing to you
and me
my girlfriend she had nothing to do with
this it's an evidence
i'm coming for you do what you have to
do
knowing how to blow stuff up that's
pretty cool
which means i need a full confession
from you five
four three
two one
ready to confess
you are never more alive than when
you're a teenager
your brain is flush with chemicals that
can turn your life into a story of epic
proportions
and yet by the start of my senior year
nothing interesting had ever happened to
me
then something finally happened
hi guys come on in
grace just transferred here from east
river i think you make a truly dynamic
editor-in-chief do you well i'll help
with editing and design just not writing
hey why'd you give up writing i was
asked to write something about someone
really important to me
i just couldn't find the words it's
funny because i can't find the words
when i talk and you can't find the words
when you write
[Music]
have you ever had a girlfriend no why
not i don't know i'm not really good at
this stuff
[Music]
i feel like i don't know anything about
you i used to be good at socializing
what changed nine months ago a car
swerved coming around a bend and flipped
[Music]
i was gonna say hot
hey grace just wanna say hi and that
hope last night just kind of meant a
tiny fraction to you as it meant to me
that was done the teenage years are
limbo hey your mom no
yeah it doesn't matter the world tells
you to express yourself but the minute
that you do it tells you to shut up
just ask her what's going on you're
right i don't know like how i'm supposed
to help i mess
up henry okay no it's not when you
realize you can't fix me
[Music]
what's wrong it's regular stuff you are
not gonna understand we're not regular
people no are you kidding me your
relationship's been perfect since you
were like my age
there is a reason why when every adult
talks about young people they can't
avoid the truth
stop leading me on i'm confused henry i
don't know i know i've known since like
the very beginning
that being young is so painful
it's almost too much to feel
[Music]
[Applause]
roman dude you have a woman now ah nice
we're getting married wait a minute what
skateboard boy
hello i think this is the place this is
it
hey youtube shut up and take our money
oh this backyard shut up and take our
money what's the catch
are you guys here for the party this is
tommy lee's sex swing
hell no i just don't feel comfortable
allowing some weirdo to live in our
guest house me
jesus it's not a kid come with me he'll
be out soon i will march out there
and i'll see you gotta get out of here
three months
[ __ ] me bro
did you have the talk with randy today i
yeah yeah
i gotta get high well whoa whoa
you're high no i'm not you're honest
just get rid of the guy
[Music]
welcome to the neighborhood you got me
[ __ ] arrested no you got you arrested
it is so on
fire i totally forgot to tell you
they're bug bombing the house today
[ __ ] go flock opossums
we just wanted a house and we found this
one and then you
the [ __ ] is going on
if that [ __ ] was on pay-per-view we'd be
[ __ ] millionaires right now
is nature a gigantic cat
and if so who strokes its back
may i introduce the brilliant nikola
tesla
the greatest inventor of the age if you
google nikola tesla you get 34 million
results
it's basically just four pictures beyond
that things get murky and more
imaginative
thomas alva edison you gotta like
oh tesla didn't see you there before i
now have the pleasure of introducing you
to a novel system of energy
alternate currents this will transform
the way the world works knows
it's perfect where you've been hiding
alternating current
is a waste of time impractical and
deadly
you live in your head doesn't everyone
you lack funding
mr tesla thinks i owe him money what was
it fifty thousand dollars yes
and morgan daughter j pierpont morgan
a woman like that can make all your
dreams come true
well my dreams are true you want
lemonade
you work at night in a secret laboratory
you
shoot lightnings from the earth to the
sky
i'm trying to team wild cat and i've
become nothing but a mass of bloody
scratches
are you like being scratched if
[Music]
necessary
[Music]
the world we are living in
is a dream that tesla dream first
[Music]
we save lives every day strangers
and there's always enough time
but i failed to save jason from this
life
joker got a hold of stolen uranium he's
selling it to terrorists
it's gonna take batman and robin
together to close this case
you take them down while i investigate
that warehouse we track joker to
please tell the big man i said hello
[Music]
i alone will become more than the dreams
and nightmares they imagined for me
the red hood's knowledge of my tactics
my history
this was getting personal
joker showed me the truth evil can't be
cured
only killed
[Music]
death
because of my choice i had to avoid
repeating mistakes
[Music]
ah the highlands one of the purest
places on earth hardly a foot has
touched
wait who the hell
okay roll call don't kid mcdonald's
team dobson pj beetroot
can i have your real name just that that
one down there william to beaufort
william oh what did you tell him to go
[ __ ] himself nice
[Music]
are you ian i'll meet you at the
campsite at 6pm
be careful we don't want to get lost in
the highlands there's danger
[Music]
oh where's the explosion
you have the whole point of a bomb
master carlisle
i've never seen a match before i'm
homeschooled
[Music]
your generation you're always
complaining always saying you
are the victim [ __ ] off
[Music]
nothing ever happened in the highlands
please say yes
[Music]
it's heaven
there you are more radiant than ever
my god still spoiling her milton
i am in a position to help financially i
can look after us
don't be too proud
twins don't know just one beautiful boy
no
i had twins again myself
she's not well we know she's not well
why are you looking at me like this
how are you feeling she hasn't had an
episode in three years she was off her
medication
how could you not know ros it's me
please
call what's going on
where are they hello
[Applause]
she took the passport and she took my
son maybe out of the country i'm gonna
call the
i need to know how this happened you're
in the state of shock
you have to get a grip
girls where's mommy i'm being followed
no more games we're not playing well
is that what you want locked up in a nut
house for the rest of your life
[Music]
[Music]
you